hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
one academic medical center's experience
with the univero multiplex platform
testing bronco alveolar lavage fluids
analytical and clinical assessment
i'm alexis krauss of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lapperts and sponsored
by opgen
a precision medicine company harnessing
the power of molecular diagnostics
and bioinformatics to help combat
life-threatening
infectious diseases and fight
anti-microbial resistance
to improve patient care for more
information about our sponsor
please visit their website at option.com
so let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click on
the send button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation report your problem by
clicking on the ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen
this by the car excuse me this webinar
is educational
and thus offers free continuing
education credits
please click on the continuing education
with window at the bottom of your screen
to obtain your credits i'd like to now
introduce our presenters for today
dr schneider director of microbiology
and infectious disease
molecular diagnostics at the university
of louisville hospital in louisville
kentucky
and dr wes hoffman infectious diseases
pharmacist
at the university of louisville jewish
hospital in louisville kentucky
for our complete biography on our
presenters please visit the biography
tab
at the top of your screen dr schneider
welcome sir you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for that introduction i'm jim
snyder
and i'd also like to thank op jan for
the invitation
to participate in this webinar today as
well as labarus for
facilitating the presentation
we will be talking about our experience
here at the university of louisville
with the univero
multiplex panel for testing
for lower respiratory tract pathogens
specifically in bronchiologe fluids
i will be discussing the technical or
the microbiological aspects
in my colleague dr wes hoffman we'll be
discussing the
antimicrobial stewardship and clinical
impact
based upon the data that was generated
from this study
as you can see the title is a little
different than the
full title representing the entire
conference but
we specifically are going to be focusing
on the
conventional microbiology culture
and detection of resistant gene markers
in which we are comparing the univero
lower respiratory tract system uh to our
current standard of practice
uh in our laboratory
it's our conflict of interest
as everyone knows we are currently and
will be for some time in an
era of rapid diagnostics
so i want to really explain in my way of
objectives
our experience
with the opt-gen univariate respiratory
tract
multiplex system and i'll begin
in a few moments with a little overview
of the operation of the system
discuss our study protocol
and then we will discuss are the
analytical performance
of the system which is as you know a
direct system
for testing in our case bals
and share with you the data regarding
our
results compared to conventional culture
including identification which is done
by multitop in our situation
in antimicrobial susceptibility testing
as it relates
to the detection of antibiotic resistant
markers
which is part of the univero system
this is an overview of the
instrumentation itself as you can see
it is a pcr based instrument with an
array detection
with high multiplexing capability
it is a closed system based upon the use
of a cartridge
barcoding and so forth another feature
is this random access
and it's a benchtop instrument
doesn't require a lot of space very
convenient
provides qualitative results
[Music]
using an algorithmic-based approach in
the computer-assisted system
and the idea is to generate
actionable results obviously rapid in
nature
to promote and influence antibiotic
stewardship
and overall patient management
you can see here the lysater this is the
control center
which they call the cockpit and then the
analyzer
and being random access that means you
can run more than one specimen at a time
uh we were running at four at a time
during our study once again
this is the compact unit that was the
fence top
and we had it in our research laboratory
the principle of the operation system is
relatively simple as you can see here
this
is the main test cartridge
once again i emphasize it's a closed
system
and in this cartridge the events
listed here take place here where the
specimen is initially lysed
followed by extraction of dna
processed for pcr
testing and the array hybridization is
related to the targets that i will show
you here in a moment
and the turnaround time for the test is
approximately four to five
hours
this is the summary of the targets
as you can see here there's
approximately 30 targets
all these bacteria including the fungus
nemesis
is definitely or are definitely
associated with
and cause pneumonia
mycoplasma is also included which as
most of you know is a very difficult
organism to grow
and sometimes you can even miss it on
the subsurface of a blood agar plate
but they will grow in culture usually in
my experience it's been
two sometimes three days but once again
it's the observation that makes it
difficult
so these are the targets that are
detected in the system itself
another part of the assay
is the detection of resistance genes
genes that are associated with carbopen
antibiotic resistant
genes at ctxn specifically for the third
generation cephalosporins
specifically esbls and the mecca
gene which is responsible for resistance
to oxacillin and or suffoxidin or both
and then the tam gene which codes for
the enzyme penicillinase
rendering the organism resistant to
penicillin
so these are the panels
in which the resistant genes and you can
see there are a plethora
of the carbopenem genes beginning with
kpc
and ranging through the oxes the mdms
and the bims
so quite a bit of
information generated in that four to
five hour time
so total 19 bacteria one fungus
and then the 10 resistive markers
this is the workflow that we followed in
our laboratory
essentially uh the the evaluation was
restricted to bronchial velar lavages
which were our primary and really only
specimen
and of course it was cultured in our
standard procedures
and we did quantitative cultures of the
bal
and our threshold is less than ten
thousand
and if there were less than ten thousand
uh did not warrant full work
up that is a full identification and
susceptibility
the threshold making it eligible for
full workup
was greater than ten thousand colony
foreign units per mil
and that included in a full id of the
pathogen
using the moldy cough and then our
antimicrobial susceptibility testing
if it was less than 10 000 there was no
further workup
it all began with the gram state we
monitored for the quality of the bal
and specifically we knew we had a bal
if we saw columnar epithelial cells
we were looking for of course like you
wouldn't enneagram stain evidence
of inflammation in the form of wbcs
and of course characterizing the
morphotypes
such as gram-positive cocci and clusters
would be morphologically suggestive of
staphyococcus
gram-negative short plump mirage would
be morphologically suggestive of
enterics
so the gram stain as most of you know is
is the most rapid the cheapest the most
informative
and the most abused test in the clinical
microbiology laboratory
but it is really where it all begins
and when it comes to assessing quality
and getting some idea of what you might
be dealing with
in that specimen because cultures are
going to be available
within the next 24 to 48 hours
with the univero system the
bal residual bal
was introduced into the lysater
and eventually the test cartridge and
within three to five
hours the assay was complete
in our particular setting we decided to
issue a preliminary report
to selected individuals and specifically
we notify the provider and the pharmd
in this case it was dr wes hoffman
for any possible action that they would
want to take
when the results were made available to
them and i'll say more about that
in our protocol
once again to emphasize we restricted
our testing to bals
only our target was 60 specimens
and our inclusion criteria included
residual bal specimens received
for quantitative bacterial culture
patients who were eligible were in icu
only
they had to be greater than 18 years of
age
and met the clinical suspicion of
bacterial pneumonia
and by the physician selectivity they
decide if this patient was suitable
to be entered into the study
specifically the candidates or the
patients for studies were selected by
either
an infectious disease physician or by
uh two i'm sorry three pulmonary
physicians
so these were the only individuals that
were permitted
to to order the test and once again
we had to have more than one ml of
residual bael
that was either fresh or refrigerated
to be eligible for testing i should
indicate we had irb approval
to conduct testing once the bal was
received in the laboratory
the processing individuals
had to check for its eligibility
beginning with the provider's name
we had a list of those providers that
were eligible
to order the test and if their name was
on the
ordering form electronically
that bal was set aside after culture
for uh universal testing
and depending on the time of day we
either tested them fresh
and i will say that the majority of them
were refrigerated
for at least 12 hours before testing
throughout the night so to speak
the exclusion criteria we were not going
to test any
non-hospitalized patients so i will
admit that
two outpatients who had bronchoscopies
slipped through the cracks
and we included those in on our
bacterial
data but not in the antimicrobial
stewardship
and clinical impact on patient
management
obviously patients who were not
suspected of having bacterial ammonia as
determined
by the eligible ordering physicians
were not included and it was very very
important
pediatrics were excluded cystic fibrosis
patients were excluded
and if we had less than one mil residual
specimen
uh that was not uh considered eligible
for testing
so that overview is our protocol and uh
what we did
was with the results with the universo
i either called the provider immediately
with the results
or or at the same time i called the
pharmd
dr wes hoffman so two individuals
usually knew the results
shortly after the univero results were
recorded
so getting into some of our data
regarding the bacterial targets as
you can see here in this bar graph
the yellow representing culture the uh
blue representing the universe and we
had a total
actually of 62 specimens the total
negative
that is negative by both uniburo and
culture was 37.
so when we said negative specimens we
indicated there was either no growth
or it was below the 10 000
colony forming units by quantitative
culture
and we've classified them as indigenous
oral flora uh
and we wanted to look at a course
concordance
for the organism targets but before i
get into that
just to show you uh the organisms that
were detected by either
culture or univero or both
and as you can see here
uh more were detected by univero
than culture for staph aureus uh four
out of four
both by for pseudomonas reginosa
uh univero
in this case detected two additional
uh e colis for a total of uh
four uh one by culture three by univero
and so forth with regards to the
remaining organisms
so once again you may say well the
database is small but we decided
statistically that we needed a minimum
of 60 specimens
to to accurately assess the performance
of
the technology so this ended up to be
that there was concordance for organisms
that has targeted organisms with a
little over 99
with positive agreement rate for
resistance genes
uh being 90 once again this is all
compared to bacterial culture
and phenotypic susceptibility testing so
there was good agreement
with the universo somewhat overall
outperforming culture which this
wasn't a surprise to me but at the same
time
it's the assessment of the culture and
the quantitation that determine
what gets worked up and what did not
this is a rather busy slide but it goes
to show you
for each of the targets that are in the
system 26
positive total
which were detected by the universe
versus 20 targets detected by
culture and i want to stress
there were off panel organisms that were
detected by culture that are not
part of the univero
target panel these include one
acromobacter xylose oxidant
one agrobacter segments there was an
enterococcus specium one
group b streptococcus but these are not
commonly regarded as agents of pneumonia
so not being in the database but
recovered in culture
on lab rounds the recommendation was
these are not pulmonary pathogens even
though they were identified
we indicated it was a learning
opportunity
for some of our technologists especially
our younger ones
that these organisms are not considered
pulmonary pathogens
and really did not need to be fully
identified
and etc yeah there could be clinical
extenuating circumstances but once again
uh when you see the universe results
many of these either had no
detection by univero but were detected
as
organisms and culture once again not
commonly regarded as pulmonary pathogens
so if we look at discordance by sample i
thought there was a very interesting
finding
you can see here that group b
streptococcus was recovered in culture
but actually the universe detected
homophobic influenzae
and we know that homophobic influenzae
is a significant cause
of pneumonia in this particular case
uh culture yielded both e coli and
enterococcus species
well once again the e coli was detected
by the universe
ephesians is not in the targeted base as
i'm not aware that ephesians
causes uh pneumonia i regard
enterococcus in most cases as a tagalong
organism
except in certain circumstances such as
bacteremia
urinary tract infections and etc
now here we have both agreement with
staff auris but this staph aureus and
culture was not worked up
because it was less than ten thousand
most likely
represented colonization but it was
detected
in the univere it was reported and it
turned out to be
methicillin resistance by virtue of the
mecca a gene being detected so once
again one could argue
that maybe this staff horse and culture
should have been worked out
but the policy is if it's less than 10
000 it is not eligible for full workout
uh based upon what we know from the
literature
and the quantitation of bals
we had several reports uh uh that
indicated indigenous oral flora well
staph aureus which was detected in the
universe
whether or not it was clinic significant
only the the clinician can decide
but staph aureus can be a colonizer and
it can also
represent a carrier state but once again
we referred to this
as indigenous oral flora similar
situation in the next
group here where we had indigenous oral
flora reported by culture
but the universe detected e coli and
staph aureus once again
having been associated with pulmonary
disease pneumonia uh whether or not they
were clinically relevant
is a clinical decision that had to be
made by the pulmonologist or the
infectious disease physician
then the intro bacterica complex
detected once again by the universe
in addition to culture yielding
klebsiella oxytoca
which was also detected by the universe
but you'll notice the univero also
targeted and detected klebsiella
pneumoniae
and citrobacter furunde all four of
these
can be associated with pneumonia once
again
we are dealing with a genomic
based system in which we are detecting
these respective organisms and what
their clinical significance is
is the responsibility of the clinician
but we're obligated to report them
there was the chromobacter xylose
oxidant which i
referred to in the previous slide
obviously it's not in the database
or the target base of the universe here
we have a staph aureus
once again proteus although regarded as
a pulmonary pathogen
was less than ten thousand commonly
forming units and was not fully worked
up
so proteus was identified based upon its
cultural characteristics
uh namely spreading and etc
but we did detect in the universe the
staph aureus
now i should advise you that the testing
was done
independently the individual conducting
the
test on the univero was blinded
to the results of culture all these
specimens were de-identified
before the individual performing the
testing
received so he had no
knowledge of what was being found in
culture
so in this particular case we have a
staph aureus also detected by univero
and once again with the proteus
there'd be no microorganisms detected in
other words
it was not detected in that particular
specimen
even though staph aureus was there
another situation of indigenous oral
flora
in this particular case streptococcus
pneumoniae was detected
and everyone knows the strep demonier is
a pathogen
that is responsible for pneumonia
here we had a situation where
pseudomonas was detected by both culture
and univero but you'll note that the
culture
uh reported out uh resistance to
cefepime and astria
pseudomonas virginosa no resistance
detected
in the universe that's because there
aren't any gene targets
for the amp c which is likely
responsible
for the resistance that we saw in the
cultural form
of the pseudomonas verginosa and then
another way of reporting
oral flora we've reported in this case
mixed oral flora
the univero happened to detect e coli
once again a pulmonary pathogen whether
or not it was clinically relevant
that would be the decision of the
provider
and possibly in consultation with the
pharmd
we had one incident where streptococcus
pneumoniae
even though it's less than a hundred
thousand in this case was detected
and but it was not detected in the
universe system
we repeated this with
what residual bal that was left over
and still did not detect streptococcus
pneumoniae
and i cannot
respond as to why or to explain
why the pneumococcus was not detected
in the by the universe but was detected
in culture
and then i mentioned the agrogratifactor
segments
which is not part of the database in the
universe system now
univero once again as you can see did
detect by virtue of the new
club pneumo and the citrobacter
additional pathogens
that were missed uh by culture
and uh once again just for your
edification the green
shading represents partial concordance
and then the off panel organisms that we
talked about
earlier are not commonly regarded
as ideological agents of pneumonia
if we look at the susceptibility testing
and the gene markers
in the universe here in the culture the
uh central bacteria complex
we detected a cre it was enzymatic based
through conformation testing
and the univero
detected and reported as a kpc
definitely a carbophenomenase resistant
anthrobacterium aca
these staph horses were mssa
the klebsiella pneumonia here the ctxm
gene was detected for this isolate and
was confirmed in culture as an espl
so that's that's good concordance once
again
two more or one more uh combination of
staph aureus by both systems
both mssa here we had a staff force that
was mrsa by culture
the mecca gene was detected by the
universe
once again mssa by both methods
pseudomonas aeruginosas these were
were susceptible and once again they
were concordance there
but in the universe it says no
resistance detected
this is an msa once again mssa
in other words no mecca detected same
for this particular situation
and of course the streptococcus
pneumoniae and so forth uh
both concurred here in that there aren't
any gene markers really
for the strep pneumo but this particular
pneumococcus was
susceptible to the common agents that
one would use
for their management and once again
pseudomonas seruginosa
susceptible no resistant markers
determined here as well
as you know in pseudomonas other name c
there are porin channel mediated
resistance there's e-flux pumps
and of course in the universe such genes
are not part of the database
so overall we had uh 37
negatives by culture 37 negatives by
univera i just wanted to point that out
again so there was excellent agreement
with culture for both pathogen id as
well as detection
of your gram positive and your
gram-negative resistant markers
and the only reason i wanted to show
this was uh the fact that the
uh this particular one with the intro
back to kawaki complex
also had the klebsiella oxytoca once
again i wanted to point out
the additional targets that were
detected by
the uh universe system in addition to
the two
that were concordant without a culture
and this is just a summary the previous
slide i think it's important
we reported an espl in culture it tells
us that this is ctxm
to consider an espl
this organism i referred to as being
resistant to cefepine
it has tree and and no resistance
detected
once again to emphasize most likely due
to amp c
mediated type of resistance and once
again
you can see for the staph aureus and
results of the
positive versus becca negatives overall
good correlation
so in conclusion the analytical
performance of the
universe lower respiratory tract
system demonstrated high correlation
to conventional bacterial culture
when testing bronchiologe and i do want
to emphasize that
other specimens can be tested on the
universe system
such as tracheoaspirates we can do
bronchial washings
but we wanted to focus specifically on
bals
because they account for the majority
of our volume of lower respiratory tract
specimens
when it comes to if you will invasive
type procedures
the univero system does allow
for ruling in or ruling out of on panel
targets
for example atypical or fastidious
pathogens
specifically the pneumocystis and
mycoplasma much faster than culture
or pneumocystis you cannot culture
but mycoplasma you can and so
this this really is a benefit to allow
for the opportunity
for the antimicrobial stewardship in
selecting appropriate therapy
in real time and we know that the
culture results in susceptibilities
usually require anywhere from two to
three days depending on the organism
so we're getting our results out much
sooner and dr
hoffman will allude to the fact at the
time
that cultural results versus the
universal results
impacted on the management of the
patient
and antimicrobial insurance ship
and of course we demonstrated an
excellent genotypic and phenotypic
correlation of isolates
and the big thing and the nice thing
about this
is it enables it provides 24 7 testing
and we are in the process
of uh justifying its acquisition
and we have been approved recently
for 24 7 dedicated microbiology staff
and this will allow us to provide
services around the clock
even with the addition of this
particular instrumentation
i would also like to acknowledge a
couple of individuals here before we
uh conclude i'd like to acknowledge dr
steve sloan who actually did the univero
testing
blinded if you will once again to
culture
dr wes hoffman who you will hear in a
few moments
was the pharmacy id who managed the
clinical impact
and the antimicrobial stewardship and
three pulmonologists who were part of
the selection process
of patients dr rodrigo cavallazi
dr alan ramirez and dr mohammad
and last but not least dr forrest arnold
infectious diseases
who also was in the process of selecting
patients
for bals and entering into the study
so with that i will thank you and
would be available for any questions
once the webinar is completed
i will now turn the program over to dr
hoffman
thank you dr schneider my name is
wes hoffman i and i'm an infectious
disease pharmacist at the university of
louisville health system
today i'll be going over the second
portion of this discussion which is
uh the clinical utility of the univarial
lower respiratory tract panel
specifically from an antimicrobial
stewardship standpoint
so as probably many of us are familiar
antimicrobial stewardship
especially in an intensive care unit
setting is number one critically
important
and number two an area of potentially
very high impact
the point prevalence of antimicrobial
use in the icu can be as high as 70
which was first identified in 1995 but
since then has
likely stayed the same or possibly even
gotten
worse in some of those settings
unfortunately only about 45 percent
of patients had a culture confirmation
of the edli
etiologic organism
and with patients in the icu as many of
us are familiar much
of the antimicrobial use involves very
broad spectrum antibiotics things like
carbopenems
vancomycin lynasolid etc
now there are some ways to combat this
effective stewardship methods
and education are going to be one key
component
to helping battle the overuse of
antimicrobials in icu settings
but that's likely likely going to be
used
in combination with rapid diagnostics
to help reduce overall how many
antibiotics are used overall how many
toxic medications are used and to
decrease the amount of
antimicrobials that are used overall
now ideally with the use of rapid
diagnostics you're going to
want some technology that has favorable
sensitivity specificity
and a negative predictive value to help
make clinical decisions that are
appropriate
in the setting of critically ill
patients
despite identification of organisms via
culture
rapid diagnostics can help decrease
unnecessary broad spectrum use by
getting you answers potential mechanisms
resistance that would otherwise take
potentially anywhere from two to four
days until you get final susceptibility
results which is how long patients may
often have to remain on broad spectrum
antimicrobials
before you can de-escalate to what may
end up being a pan-susceptible organism
the other factor that comes into play
here is is for some idsa guidelines
especially in the setting of pneumonia
combination therapy is often recommended
in things like ventilator associated
pneumonia
oftentimes with aminoglycosides given
the high amount of resistance that can
be found in icus
if you have to continue these
combination therapies that are
exceptionally broad spectrum that
increases the risk of adverse events
and potential development of resistance
later on
now the study that we did here with
univero which
to our knowledge is the first time that
this has been done prospectively
was to take patients who were in icu
care who had a bronchial v or lavage
done for diagnostic purposes
and it was evaluated with the univero
lower respiratory tract panel
this was done in addition to standard
culture and susceptibility testing which
is always going to be a component
done in conjunction with the universe
now the results from the univaro were
communicated to the primary team
in this study when the results were
available and
they were also reported to the
infectious disease pharmacist
who's a member of the antimicrobial
stewardship team
we had 15 patients included in the
clinical evaluation
of this study and
as we can note here de-escalation
occurred in 33
of patients now this was sometimes just
de-escalation of mrsa therapy
sometimes just the escalation of
anti-pseudomonal therapy
and at times it was a combination of
de-escalating from mrsa and
anti-pseudomonal therapy
percent of patients ended up having an
escalation occur one of these cases
involving a carbopentamise producer
another case involving esbl
times when we were not adequately
covering what the patient ended up
having identified and subsequently
confirmed in culture
overall a little bit over half of
patients had
some change made with the universe lower
respiratory tract panel
and oftentimes this was done faster than
conventional methods
so the results that were reported as i
mentioned earlier were reported the
infectious disease pharmacist who then
discussed with the team
at the earliest potential opportunity
the
clinical ramifications of what those
results
demonstrated and as i said earlier the
changes in therapy
often occurred significantly faster than
with conventional methods so
with our group of patients here on
average it was a 21-hour faster
change in therapy with univera results
and this ranged anywhere from
zero hours meaning we couldn't really
make any change
all the way up to a little under two
days sooner
now the little asterisk here is that
this is compared to when
susceptibilities resulted
because this is not a head-to-head trial
of doing
some patients with the univero panel and
some patients without there's no way we
can really tell how soon they would have
changed
based on the susceptibilities reported
so this is
perhaps a more conservative estimate
knowing full well that when
susceptibilities are reported oftentimes
those are not seen for anywhere from an
hour to until potentially the next day
now when it comes to how to utilize
univero this is kind of the method that
we ended up following
and the first two are relatively easy to
do
for for anybody involved so escalation
obviously if you identify something that
you're currently not covering say
somebody is on ceftrax and you identify
pseudomonas that's an
easy use of the unit vero to get them on
appropriate therapy right away
if you have them on cefepime and you
identify e coli
with a third generation cephalosporin
resistance gene such as ctxm which is
identified by univero
that would allow you to rapidly escalate
someone to a carbopenum
uh and it's a fairly simple task to do
the other aspect which is particularly
easy to use
is the de-escalation of mrsa therapy now
largely in icu settings vancomycin or
nasal it is really going to be utilized
almost exclusively for mrsa given that
the negative predictive value of
universe for staph aureus is about 97
and knowing that potentially half of
those
can be mssa that really gives you
a pretty solid indication that mrsa is
not present and causing
infection in this patient at least from
a respiratory standpoint
now of course univiro doesn't take the
place of
something like positive blood cultures
in the setting of endocarditis but
this is to be used for the clinical
diagnosis of pneumonia
and by being able to de-escalate from
mrsa therapy
there's really three major benefits to
that number one
you're not using that drug that's that's
helping that patient
that's reducing the cost of the drug
it's mitigating the potential for
adverse effects such as vancomycin
induced nephrotoxicity which is
of course very well described and lastly
it's also a reduction in cost
of managing vancomycin
in these settings so that requires
additional blood draws
to get levels done sometimes two if your
institution is doing area under the
curve monitoring and doing a two-level
evaluation
it also saves pharmacists time who
otherwise have to manage
both the levels and the calculations and
the changes in doses
of vancomycin so those are the two easy
ones escalation
overall and de-escalation of mrsa
therapy
where it gets to be a little bit
trickier but
arguably sometimes more useful is the
de-escalation in gram negative therapy
so a quick disclaimer with this this is
of course as i said not as simple as
de-escalating from mrsa therapy
because there are various gram-negative
organisms and
they can have significant differences
in how they become resistant
antimicrobials
you really need to use univero in
conjunction with your local antibiogram
and resistance data
as well as knowledge of basic resistance
mechanisms and gram negatives
now that being said the use of a
negative predictive value for species
and resistance factors can still help
you make a decision
on what would be appropriate therapy for
that patient
but knowledge of mechanisms of
resistance and phenotypes are still
critical to making those decisions
so when it comes to gram negative
therapy and potential de-escalation
negative results for any organism
altogether can
can still help make a decision for you
or at least
give you an idea of what direction to go
so with nothing being identified in the
patient who clinically has pneumonia
generally speaking that may give you an
idea that you could potentially
de-escalate from anti-pseudomonal
therapy altogether
not get rid of gram-negative therapy
altogether but at least de-escalate from
anti-pseudomonal therapy
now of course you have to take into
consideration your hospitals common
organisms
there is one particular organism the
universe does not identify which is
enterobacter erogenese which is now
called cielo erogenese
but generally speaking for what mostly
you're going to see in an icu this can
be very helpful by knowing that
a common gram negative is not causing
infection the other consideration to
take into account
is that some patients have very
obviously patient-specific factors that
accompany them
so patients with cystic fibrosis or
severe bronchiectasis may sometimes
harbor something like berkeled area
which is not identified by univero
but if univero is negative and that
patient has a history of birkeldera
you're probably not going to de-escalate
in that sitting
that's a overall probably a significant
minority of patients that will have
something like this going on in the icu
so this can still be useful you just
always have to keep those patient
specific factors in mind
the other thing to keep in mind
especially for stewardship programs is
that willingness to de-escalate may
depend
on the patient's clinical status and the
comfort level of the primary team i'm
sure we're all familiar with
patients who are very critically ill
and possibly on for pressers and
quite honestly fear drives a lot of
antimicrobial use especially in icus
primary teams may not necessarily want
to rock the boat if a patient has
improved ever so slightly on combination
therapy
even though logically they may trust the
results of this
it may be difficult to in real time
de-escalate
drastically in this setting they may
want to wait till the next day and
that's understandable
i'm sure many of us have been burned by
missing an organism from time to time
but with that being said the the very
nice thing
about univero is that pseudomonas and
acidobacter both have a
negative predictive value with universe
of 98
oftentimes it is unlikely the
anti-pseudomonal therapy
will help in those settings particularly
extremely broad spectrum agents
like carbopenums
now when organ when identifying specific
organisms
such as e coli for example
once again knowledge of your local
resistance factors are going to be
key so in this kind of algorithmic box
here e coli is identified
as we know from an earlier slide and the
discussion with dr snyder
resistance genes are going to be
identified
by univero to the extent of what that
panel covers so ctxm
is an example of that and that's largely
related to cephalosporin resistance and
espl activity
in the setting of e coli luckily
e coli usually becomes an espl
by using the ctxm gene that is the most
common mechanism to have an espl
phenotype
so if that gene is identified it allows
you to escalate quickly to maripin if
that patient was not already on it
however if that gene is not identified
it's not to say that there's no chance
of espl but it's a very low chance
especially if you know your hospital
antibiogram particularly well
in that setting generally speaking
ceftriaxone is going to be active there
are some rare cases where plasma
mediated amp c betalactamases can be
present in e coli
but oftentimes that represents one
percent or less of isolates
so oftentimes you can de-escalate off of
anti-pseudomonal therapy
to something like ceftriaxone if e coli
is identified
so that is one of the mechanisms by
which univero can be useful and you
don't have to wait for
final phenotypic susceptibility tests to
make an adjustment
in the next example uh let's take
something like pseudomonas aeruginosa
being identified
as most of us know pseudomonas has
multiple resistance mechanisms
that are extremely diverse and are also
not
recognized by univero these include
things like amp cd repression which can
lead to resistance
with cefepime peptazo and ceftazidime
can also have porn mutations which can
lead to resistance
with carbopenum so in a setting like
this
using univero plus your local
antibiogram data and knowledge of these
resistance mechanisms can still help
guide appropriate therapy for your
pseudomonas
even without telling you what the
resistance factors are
for example idsa guidelines suggest
doing combination therapy
for half and fat for critically ill
patients
because of the likelihood of significant
resistance in some of these grab
negative organisms
if you've identified pseudomonas that
makes you feel far more comfortable
about continuing that combination
therapy even though it involves an agent
that is potentially more toxic like an
aminoglycoside knowing that
you're actually potentially getting some
benefit out of it compared to something
like e coli without any resistance
factors you may feel far more
comfortable
just doing one agent rather than come
combining with an amine glycoside
because you know that a beta-lactam
especially if you're going broad with
miropenum
is highly unlikely to miss any of those
organisms
the utilization of univero plus your
knowledge of gram-negative resistance
specifically in pseudomonas can still
help
guide appropriate therapy even if it
remains broad
in the setting of combination therapy
now that is largely the three methods by
which we utilized
univero and hopefully helpful in some
ways that you can utilize this
technology to help
de-escalate or escalate when appropriate
as we found in this evaluation the
universal lower rest
track lower respiratory tract panel can
provide rapid and actionable results
particularly if used in conjunction with
an active antimicrobial stewardship
program
the negative predictive values of
univero
can be extremely useful in reducing
excessive exposure to unnecessary
antimicrobials
particularly mrsa therapy and at times
carbopenum and anti-pseudomonal therapy
now with all that being said while
univero can be useful on its own
knowledge of resistance mechanisms of
some of these key organisms
and knowledge of your local resistance
rates
are likely going to be necessary in
combination with univero
to make the best possible decisions for
patients that you're seeing
while univer as we said can be useful on
its own really the best way to get the
most out of it is to use this
combination
approach to help guide therapy and avoid
any adverse effects
thank you very much for listening to
this we will move on to the
q a portion of this series
please if anybody has any questions let
us know and we would be happy to discuss
further
thank you
thank you dr snyder and dr hoffman for
your informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started dr snyder it looks
like our first question is for you
your data shows very good correlation
between the universo and quantitative
culture id
so it looks like the qualitative
reporting scheme or
call logic of the universe system works
well and no
reporting bins are needed
that is correct once again the good
correlation is such that
how we report in the laboratory uh
from the standard uh practice versus
what
we were reporting from the uh you know
bureau we're confident
because of the good correlation that
we are generating data that is very
useful
to our provider as well as the farm d
great thank you dr snyder moving on to
our next question dr hoffman i
i have one for you here and this looks
to be a two-part question
what are the limitations of this panel
and the second part is
and are the limitations specific to this
panel or
general limitations
uh yes so the the limitations of the
panel are
obviously the panel only covers what it
covers
uh so you know there are times as we
discussed with the burkledaria
example that you know you're just going
to miss some organisms and so knowing
patient-specific histories is always
important
the other limitation which i think is
worth repeating but generally fairly
obvious that this is limited to
respiratory tract infections so you know
especially in critically ill patients
there can be a lot of stuff
going on um so
you know somebody clinically appears
infected and it's
likely pneumonia but there's maybe some
concern for intra-abdominal
source of infection as well uh that's
gonna obviously be a limitation that
even if you utilize you know vero
to try to identify
some pathogen from the respiratory tract
if there's still a concern for some
other source of infection somewhere else
that may not allow you to utilize that
as much
unless of course you identified some
escalation opportunity from the
respiratory tract
but de-escalation may be a little bit
harder in that standpoint
great thank you dr hoffman and our next
question
is how useful is semi-quantification in
pneumonia panels
dr snyder or dr hoffman do we still have
you
this question could be for for either of
you
i'll take it and then if dr hoffman has
any comments
fine uh i have very little confidence in
the
semi-quantitative pneumonia panels it's
from our perspective and experience and
talking to others it's very difficult to
really assess
the true clinical relevance
of those quantitative data that are
coming off in pneumonia panels
they they use an algorithm-based
system and once again
[Music]
i personally or we personally do not use
the pneumonia panels but talking to
others that do
and following the literature there are
questionable
areas as to the clinical relevance
and overall interpretation and
correlation with
standard culture if you will so i think
there's
room for improvement on these pneumonia
panels
and that's why we do these studies to
cite areas of limitations that require
further investigation
great thank you so much dr snyder so we
have time for a few more questions i do
want to remind our audience that those
questions we are unable to answer today
and those that come in during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by our speakers via
the contact information that you
provided
at the time of registration
and so it looks like our final question
is going to be
for dr snyder you mentioned that there
was educational opportunity
for your lab staff and reporting
respiratory culture result
results and what is the pathogen that
should be
reported and what is not a respiratory
pathogen
how do you go about this type of
education in your lab
a couple ways with regards to the study
that we conducted i would get the
results
and then i would compare those to what
the
laboratory for generating and when i saw
discordant results i would go to the
technologist that was responsible for
generating the result
and we would have a discussion as to
why this pat or this organism was
identified when we know that it's not
a customary agent of pneumonia
this was an educational opportunity
for the technologists and we're
fortunate to have uh
probably 30 percent of our younger
technologists on board who are learning
every day
like the rest of us as we do the other
mechanism is through our daily
laboratory rounds
and we use the keystra
tla and uh there is a
box on the dashboard
that the text reading cultures and so
forth
can put a question in under my name
so in addition to coming by every day
for lab rounds we also look for those
questions
and those are educational opportunities
so it's just a matter of
sharing with the staff
the nature and overall clinical
core or clinical
association of these organisms as they
relate
in this case to pneumonia or whatever
other infections so
once again it depends on the
specimen type as far as the study was
concerned
those discordant uh isolates that we had
identified in the clinical laboratory
but not part of the univera database
this is an opportunity to
share with the technologists why these
organisms did not require full workup
and once again that's purely educational
and we see consistency
more and more each day with regards to
what we've learned previously in course
lab rounds it's the opportunity to see
not only unique
situations but to answer questions for
those techs that are assessing the
cultures
thank you so much dr snyder before we go
i would like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will
be addressed by our speakers via the
contact information that you provided at
the time of registration
we would also like to once again thank
dr snyder and dr hoffman for their time
today
and for their important research we'd
also like to thank labyrinth and our
sponsor offgen
for underwriting today's educational
webcast you can view the webinar on
demand
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and until next time
bye everyone